[Music]  Tiffany and you won't believe what she's  talking about now yep Tiffany's more  than ready to be glamorous September  issue cover girl but she also can't  resist cracking us up while posing or  reacting to different dating scenarios  like I like this pad has the comedic  chops but which career would she choose  outside of comedy quote I would probably  be a sex education teacher I guarantee  none of my kids would have STDs after I  finished teaching them thank you thank  you  as for the twice-divorced 38 year-olds  own love life she's not seeing any one  specific quote I done ran through 38  dudes okay I've had enough somebody's  gotta love her candor and when Tiffany  hears her honesty has made someone feel  more confident this is her reaction no  joke thank you can you just made my  whole day by telling me  [Music]